vt and leila per Ola grazie Presidente
honorable members of the Parliament the
December European Council will be marked
by a change of guards so to speak it
will be the first meeting to be chaired
by President Charles Michel and pending
your approval of the new Commission
tomorrow it will also be the first one
for elephant a lion in her capacity as
president of the Commission and for the
new high representative Joseph Borel
the agenda will be dominated by two
pressing issues climate change and the
multi-annual financial framework let me
start by climate change you will all
recall that in June the European Council
came close to an agreement on climate
neutrality by 2050 however a few member
states felt they needed more time to
assess the efforts and costs linked to
the transition to climate neutrality
before committing the shots ambitious
target the European Council therefore
asked the council and the Commission to
advance work on the conditions
incentives and enabling framework and
pledged to finalize its guidance before
the end of the year with a view to the
adoption and submission of the EU long
term strategy to the United Nations
Framework Convention on Climate Change
in early 2020 in December the European
Council will aim to commit that year to
reach in climate neutrality by 2050 and
identify the enabling framework that
will allow us to reach that objective
the presidency has worked intensively
with other member states and the
Commission in order to facilitate this
decision the discussion in this plenary
yesterday again highlighted the need for
the EU to act decisively in order to
remain a world leader in climate issues
this brings me to the second topic on
the European Council agenda the
multi-annual financial
the Finnish presidency will submit a
finalized negotiation box with figures
prepared on the basis of the exchange
abuse that took place in Council
preparatory bodies as well as bilateral
discussions with all the locations we
intend to submit the negotiation box in
the coming few days honourable members
we are nearing the end stage of
negotiations I believe it's all our
interest to reach an agreement on the
next mff soon in order to make sure our
citizens regions farmers universities
and other beneficiaries can continue
their work uninterrupted the presidency
stop in this respect has not been easy
the individual positions being wide
apart with a brexit cap the status quo
is not an option
we will have to pay more and
unfortunately some will have to receive
less the leaders discussed and therefore
should identify the most important
issues and prepare the ground for the
future compromise honorable members I'm
glad to say we have had many fruitful
exchanges with the EP during the course
of this process in this plenary we have
discussed the MFF already and I'm glad
that we could organize an informal
breakfast discussion last week in
Brussels between the Member States and
the negotiations of the European
Parliament the member states found this
exchange useful and timely thank you
very much for that without going to full
details of the Presidency's proposal I
am pleased to note the positions of the
Parliament and the council converge in
several important areas first of all the
next mff should be able to deliver on
the policy set out in the strategic
agenda ambition on climate policy
commitment to chest transition in Greece
the investments to research and
development and a comprehensive
management of migration are just a few
key policies the next mff will be able
to address as in the Commission proposal
the presidency is committed to renewing
to renewing and modernizing the EU
budget by giving modern programs the
largest share of EU funds however we
also note the importance of cohesion
policy to the unity and success of the
Union as well as the need to devote
sufficient funds to our farmers so that
they can continue to develop sustainable
agriculture the presidency will also
propose to make a strong link between
protecting the EU budget from
generalised deficiencies in the area of
rule of law and furthermore new owned
resources should be decided in order to
diversify the financing of the EU s
budget dear friends we have no illusions
that there will be disappointments in
our proposal that is inevitable in a
process seeking to find common ground
not everybody can just get what they
want but it is now sincere belief that
our proposal represents a balanced way
forward the European added value and our
political priorities will guide us to
deliver results over the next seven
years the European Council will give
further guidance to the Union on the way
forward with the objective of reaching a
final agreement it is furthermore
possible that leaders will discuss
certain external affairs issues in the
light of developments on the
international stage
in any event following the Normandy
format summits scheduled for December
9th in Paris the European Council will
assess progress in the implementation of
the Minsk agreements and decide whether
to renew the economic sanctions against
Russia for another six months and we
also mentioned that there will be a euro
summit in an exclusive format to take
stock of progress made in the Euro group
on the implementation of
the June euro summit statement and
finally breaks it will again be on
leaders agenda on Friday the European
Council is expected to have a short
meeting in its article 50 format leaders
will discuss the next steps in light of
recent developments thank you very much
mr. president for your attention gratz
yeah this wrapper Ola France Timmerman
misha Presidente recommissioning prego
that's a president dear friends I have
to start by saying that this is the last
time I come before you as standing for
president jean-claude Juncker and I want
to use that opportunity to thank him for
his leadership over five years but most
of all from my perspective to thank him
for his friendship for his wisdom for
his wit his endless source of anecdotes
jean-claude is what in the Jewish
tradition is called a mensch and I will
miss him as I think we all will and we
owe him I think a big debt of gratitude
for what he's done for Europe in the
last five years assists the restrict him
to glide in our patient of that animal
patient Thursday and Friday for future
sumon resent the sun's own control dish
with one's own planet and sock fetish
again then this is the goon lagoons oh
Allah to comfort our oppa had success
help us by track some people I come from
Paris that superf lifted the tripods gas
emission in the obits unseat Isaac
Mendez first export sense of illusion
topic on will almost mayor awry him as
overpaid Commission VN my own staff your
own Jetson
does the overpressure hat and air guide
series and air guide to give a steel
wish list
I hope as Otis 2050 so I'm climbin or
incontinent really then we have Nick
Manto Tom Frieden a stick in a red zone
zone of omission of an a4 hi to hole in
the belt I
also arpeggio strategy mustn't signal
and the climate conference event not
zones then on and Rafa tracks patent
m-files
so air guides egrants in an spawn the
OPA F net desire guides of an average
Africa schnozzle this the parotid and
climber neutrals of openness that we
industry order autos observes Ananda
Sundra fat so again on the industry
chickens fit design via member yet of
green on innovative at egg nog eens
etson secret as long as technique no
insulting eaten zone on all on the verge
shaft as launched out of Europa in the
era inject climate master Sylvia
suppress no madam Jamis early deputy
until besoin de procedure canoes
ambition OC Lublin SSS wat el resto ho
let her mod sinan disposal par des
moines Afanasieff is own pool a concrete
easy par example
profit and releases of achieved lockable
party in european drove the d-block a
decent and amiodarone a vest is mostly
mater sacani use condom entrance sip
aqua new new samsung has a investi home
advance empezando not reportable j a
long-term don't a question climatic a
Pascal IDO not responsibility de firma
sort kimi o con leche por cuanto la
transition verb in economy pre-modern
equip a vacant system energetic preserve
open a bleep pop on a lobster
transitions soffit maple races adverb
benefit co2 laser pathology or opener
Pavan la vista social la cuestión
economic socially territorial la
solidarity entre les etymology de de la
solidarity auto regeneration not robust
all the Tetra lavinia
eden consiguen Donizetti Giordano's
entrepreneurship sheldon origin do novel
I do know company a set of near not OPA
Luton press to Qatar Doha negotiations
with a possible GOP Apple will appear
doom Advantium
do
set risk the person please the
compliment well Amazon of Anton ville de
politic Dulhaniya le Lu conceived opened
Odessa mow do da dong ed LoCascio
O'Donovan episode decisive as a
negotiation Franco knew prisión para
venir an ACOG Oprah affiliate Dimitra on
meda meda meda sweet said commission
fellow schwa Buju reasonable hero
present observable on spots on you have
new National Grid Alinea handset Papa's
eco model a de la política Agricole
commune l a political cohesion cohesion
ever flatly nouvelle politic the
determine walnut revenue cinema on the
labs on pellagra search political
tolerance mathematic poor Lavinia donors
earn polynomial ich bin mayor gestured
emigration in a palace for the reduction
its way on Syria come on say Tony Kanaan
portion between European the
contribution national AG not pass code
on ley de casa la a priciple no dual
inflation la croissants economic a
common opposite met kisser a beaucoup
press a key table POTUS the Supreme a
Lahab a non certain pay benefits
benefits e poder a historic alpha
leopard on Padova color description so
they sought net it will force
description Baskerville Abruzzi a twin
European tool money gang control
Felicia's ensemble amplifier and video
Elmo mr. president honourable members I
would like to finish with a few remarks
ahead of the Euro summit we cannot talk
about your future our efforts to ensure
it is sustainable and with the right
budget to meet a citizens needs without
the understanding that strengthening our
economic and monetary union is a
fundamental component for our success
the good news is that there is a
consensus on the principle elements
needed to continue doing this and even
better news because progress on this
important work is well within reach this
includes the first-ever budgetary
instrument for convergence and
competitiveness in the euro area which
the main features have now been agreed
secondly on the
instability mechanism which by its very
existence already increases resilience
in the area area the legal framework
still falls short of the political
reality which must also include its role
as a backstop to the single resolution
fund and thirdly on the completion of
the banking Union on this last point I
would like to underline that when the
banking union was launched it was always
going to be based on three pillars
supervision resolution and the third
missing pillar a European Deposit
Insurance Scheme it has been four years
since the Commission made a proposal in
two years since we proposed pragmatic
solutions to find a compromise between
the Parliament and the council progress
is long overdue I want to welcome the
ongoing work of the high-level working
group in this regard and on behalf of
the Commission and my colleagues
Dombrowski's and Muscovy C I look
forward to seeing an outcome of this
work and an agreement on how to put this
into practice we may be subject to
political cycles I said something about
this at the beginning that is the nature
of democracy the same should not apply
to our economy here we need to ensure
stability over the last five years we've
been deepening the economic monetary
union precisely because doing so is
making our economy stronger and more
resilient to stress in the face of
increasing pressure in our external
environment we need this resilience at
home we are before the biggest challenge
humanity has ever faced and we need to
prepare for it well thank you very much
mr. president
grazie a
[Applause]